no es el único ataque en la ciudad ni en
la región varios ataques se dieron esta
noche y en los tres últimos días han
sido atacados varios sectores en las
autoridades hablan de 25 heridos algunos
muy pocos muertos dicen que
afortunadamente que ha sido casi un
milagro especialmente en esta región
donde anoche no murió nadie las personas
que habitaban aquí dicen que realmente
no entiende hablar entrábamos a la casa
de una mujer donde la puerta estaba casi
en la pared del otro lado ella dice que
se pudo salvar gracias a que estaba en
ese momento en el baño pero esta es una
de lg el ejemplo de las consecuencias de
esta ofensiva para tomar la región del
donbass aquí creen que lo que están
haciendo las fuerzas rusas es bajar
desde el norte para tratar de rodear la
ciudad encerrar a las fuerzas ucranianas
y dejarlas aquí para hacer esa ofensiva
y tomar el control de la región sin
embargo las autoridades dicen que ellos
han tenido 70 días para prepararse en un
principio pensaron que la ofensiva iba a
comenzar por aquí luego pudieron
preparar si no solamente eso que la
llegada de armamento occidental ha
realmente apoyado al ejército y está
preparado para detener el avance de las
fuerzas rusas que se dicen que no están
avanzando con la velocidad que se
esperaba o que preveían los analistas